how big is 2 to 256 well it's 2 to 32
multiplied by itself 8 * 2 32 is about 4
billion suppose you have a really good
computer that runs 4 billion operations
per second and imagine 4 billion of
those computers this is something like a
thousand times the number of computers
that Google has Earth has about 8
billion people so imagine giving half of
every individual on the planet their own
personal killer Google then imagine a
Galaxy that has 4 billion copies of this
Earth take 4 billion copies of this
Galaxy and we'll call it your Giga
Galactic supercomputer let that run for
4 billion seconds 126.80 then let it run
for 4 billion times that 37 times the
age of the universe even still it falls
short of 2 to the 256 operations you
would have to do all of that again 4
billion times so if someone describes a
cryptographic protocol as having 256bit
security let's just say that it means a
Brute Force attack would take a damn
long time